[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
Slomka guten Abend für die Menschen in
der Ukraine war das heute wieder ein
besonders furchtbarer Tag die Russen
haben ein klein Dorf in der Region
harkif unter Beschuss genommen mehr als
50 Menschen sind dadurch ums Leben
gekommen viele der Opfer hatten wohl zum
Zeitpunkt der Bombardierung in einem
cffee zusammengesessen nach einer
Trauerfeierlichkeit das muss wohl das
sein was Vladimir Putin meinte als er
bei einer öffentlichen Veranstaltung
heute sagte Russland stehe für
konstruktive Kooperation mit allen die
nach Frieden und Wohlstand Streben
einene brül ist für uns in der Ukraine
und berichtet über das Grauen von
grosa es sind Bilder die kaum zu
ertragen sind
tote
Hinterbliebene
Retter großer ein kleiner Ort den kaum
jemand kannte es zum Symbol geworden für
die Unerbittlichkeit mit der Russland
seinen Angriffskrieg
führt wir waren im Zentrum des Dorfs als
wir plötzlich die Explosion gehört haben
ich bin hierhergekommen weil meine
Mutter auch
kurz nach 13 Uhr trifft eine russische
eskanderrakete den Ort in der Region
hakif im Osten der Ukraine kommt her
bitte ruft dieser Mann dort liegen noch
viele
Menschen bis zur Front sind es 40 km die
Anwohner hier haben sich sicher gefühlt
ihren Alltag gelebt
Kriegsalltag hier war ein Kaffee nach
der Beerdigung eines Soldaten haben sich
alle getroffen
das Innenministerium überprüft ob jemand
den genauen Standort an die Russen
weitergegeben hat weil der Angriff so
präzise war so viele Opfer gefordert hat
das Ziel vielleicht auch ausgesucht
wurde weil man Soldaten vor Ort
vermutete zu Beginn des Kriegs hatten
die Russen großer besetzt 7 Monate
lang das Dorf ist klein hier wohnten nur
300 bis 350 Menschen während der
Besatzung sind viele Einwohner
geflohen
die Ukraine spricht von mehr als 50
Toten die Staatsanwaltschaft Rake
vermittelt Beweise werden gesammelt so
ist das immer wenn russische
Kriegsverbrechen vermutet
werden Staatsanwälte und der mitler
Arbeiten vor Ort sie analysieren Trümmer
sie sammeln Informationen über die Opfer
und über die Art von Waffen die bei
diesem Angriff eingesetzt
wurden für D Tage wurde Trauer
ausgerufen in es war der tödlichste
Angriff in der Region seit Beginn des
Kriegs begleitet von diesen
Horrornachrichten aus der Heimat trat
Präsident zelenski beim großen
Europatreffen in Granada auf in der
andalusischen Stadt versammelte sich
heute quasi ganz Europa also auch Länder
die nicht oder noch nicht Mitglied in
der EU sind der EU-Gipfel im engeren
Sinne findet dann morgen statt die
Themen werden an beiden Tagen weitgehend
dieselben sein die Kriege und Krisen
dieses Kontinents
Ulf Röller
berichtet der Gastgeber wollte es an
klanz nicht fehlen lassen ein Moment in
dem der Gipfel inne hielt trotz der
vielen Krisen Begrüßung der
Regierungschefs durch den König vor
einer besonderen Kulisse die Alhambra
hat viele Herrscher gesehen ein Symbol
der Macht aber auch ein Symbol eines
Europas der vielen Kulturen der Gipfel
fängt am Morgen mit einer Ermahnung an
die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wir brauchen Solidarität
und Einheit nicht nur der europäischen
Regierungen sondern auch der
europäischen
Bevölkerung wieder einmal ist selenski
auf einem Gipfel wieder einmal wird er
umarmt und hoffiert und doch geht die
Angst bei vielen um dass die Kraft ihn
zu unterstützen nachlässt in Europa und
vor allem in den USA am Morgen wirkt er
deshalb nachdenklich und auch ein wenig
müde es wird wieder ein Tag für die
Ukraine mit vielen Opfern umso
eindringlicher sein
Appell für uns ist es sehr wichtig wir
brauchen einen militärischen
Schutzschild für den
Winter denn Russland wird uns mit
Raketen und drohen
angreifen ein Journalist fragt haben sie
Angst dass Amerika und Europa sie im
Stich
lassen wir der Ukraine haben aufgehört
Angst zu haben wir leben im Krieg wir
haben keine Angst wir müssen
kämpfen der ungarische Präsident Orban
zweifelt dagegen an den siegschancen der
Ukraine er sperrt sich immer wieder
gegen die europäische Unterstützung
blockiert
Hilfsgelder umso wichtiger für selenski
dass die anderen Waffen liefern alle
blicken da auf den Kanzler ein weiteres
Flugabwehrsystem Patriot verspricht er
selenski aber beim Waffensystem Taurus
bleibt Scholz hart der Kanzler ist
vorsichtig und dazu zählt ganz besonders
die Tatsache dass wir selbstverständlich
gewährleisten müssen dass es keine
Eskalation des Krieges gibt und dass
auch Deutschland nicht Teil der
Auseinandersetzung wird das ist auch
meine Aufgabe als Bundeskanzler das zu
gewährleisten der Bundeskanzler in
krisendauereinsatz zweites Treffen
zweiter Konflikt diesmal der zwischen
Aserbaidschan und Armenien die Europäer
wollten auf dem Gipfel vermitteln aber
dann sagte der aserbaidschanische
Präsident einfach ab der nächste
Konflikt rot militärisch zu eskalieren
wir sollten jetzt den ernsthaften
Versuch machen dafür zu sorgen dass ein
dauerhafter Friede gesichert werden kann
zwischen Aserbeidschan und Armenien dass
es keine Grenzkonflikte gibt dass
niemand versucht Land des anderen
gewissermaßen militärisch zu erobern am
Ende eines gipfeltages noch einmal Glanz
noch einmal große Kulisse für das
Familienfoto
aber es ist nur ein Bild von einem
Gipfel mit vielen
Krisen wie geht es weiter mit der
Unterstützung für die Ukraine mit der
europäischen Sicherheit darüber wollen
wir mit Christoph heuskgen sprechen dem
Chef der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
ein erfahrener Diplomat ehemals
sicherheitspolitischer Berater der
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel guten Abend her
husken guten Abend from man hat man so
die Kommentare und Beobachtungen dieses
Gipfels oder auch der letzten Tage liest
und sieht zu den eruck die Unterstützung
für die Ukraine bröckelt und auch Herr
selenski sieht zunehmend besorgt aus
teilen Sie diese Sorge ja wenn man die
Nachrichten aus den USA verfolgt das
Ergebnis der Wahlen in der Slowakei da
kann einem schon m ein bisschen kann man
etwas besorgt werden auf der anderen
Seite äh die Waffen werden ja weiter
geliefert es gibt sehr viele Staaten die
stehen dahinter und Präsident Biden hat
ja auch versichert dass er alles tun
wird damit er weiter ähm die Ukraine mit
den notwendigen Waffen unterstützen kann
mhm wenn sie gerade sagen Waffen werden
weitergeliefert aber gerade heute nun
hat Bundeskanzler Scholz noch mal
durchblicken lassen dass der Taurus
diese Marschflugkörper um die die
Ukraine schon seit langem bittet nicht
liefern will er befürchte eine
Eskalation ließ sich aus seinen
Äußerungen ablesen wie meint er das wie
schätzen Sie diese Befürchtung ein also
zunächst mal muss man ja auch
feststellen dass Deutschland zwar immer
gezögert hat bei der liefer von Waffen
aber mittlerweile nach den USA ja der
zweitgrößte Lieferant von Waffen ist da
wird sehr viel getan ich glaube auch
dass das versprochene Patriot System
sehr hilfreich sein kann bei Taurus
ist das ist eine besondere Waffe eine
sehr effektive Waffe die im übrigen ja
schon
geliefert wird vergleichsweise
geliefert wird von Engländern und
Franzosen und die Sorge die der
Bundeskanzler hat ist dass man beim
Einsatz dieses Waffensystems äh
vielleicht
Daten aus Deutschland braucht oder dass
es deutsche Programmierer braucht also
deutsche Soldaten auf dem Boden der
Ukraine und das ist etwas das muss man
ernst nehmen auf der anderen Seite hört
man von Franzosen und Britten dass
mittlerweile die Ukrainer selbst die
notwendigen Daten liefern und selbst
auch programmieren können und dann sehe
ich keine Bedenken warum wir nicht im
Verbund mit England und Frankreich diese
sehr wichtigen machtschulkörper ähm dann
tatsächlich liefern sollten könnte es
sein dass die Sorge ist dass diese
Marschflugkörper von Militärs als das
Mittel der Wahl eingeschätzt werden um
die kerschbrücke zur Krim schwer zu
treffen oder auch tatsächlich zu
zerstören was die britischen und
französischen Systeme wohl so effektiv
und V all aus so weiter Entfernung nicht
könnten also ähm es ist wichtig und das
hat selenski ja zugesagt dass diese
Waffen äh nur eingesetzt werden um ähm
ukrainisches um auf ukrainischem
Territorium Position der Russen ist was
die krmia ist klar und wenn dann die
kerbrisse getroffen würde eine die gegen
Völkerrecht dort gebaut worden ist
wenn man die dann auf sozusagen auf
ukrainischem völkerrechtlich
ukrainischem Territorium trifft dann ist
das ein legitimes Ziel und es wäre sogar
ein wichtiges Ziel weil dadurch ja
der Nachschub für die russischen Truppen
dann auch unter brochen werden würde und
das ist ja die Voraussetzung Frau wir
müssen ja immer denken was ist das Ziel
das Ziel muss doch sein dass wir endlich
Frieden bekommen dort und wir sehen dass
Putin weitermacht und nur wenn Putin das
Gefühl hat dass er seine Ziele nicht
erreichen kann dass tatsächlich die
Ukraine erfolgreich ist nur dann wird er
ja zu Verhandlungen bereit sein also
deswegen ist es ja so wichtig umfrieden
zu bekommen dass wir die Ukraine stärken
ihr Territorium es geht ja nicht um
Angriffe auf die Russland es geht um
darum dass sie ihr eigenes Territorium
zurückgewinnen man wird es stattdessen
ein weiteres Patriot System geben wenn
man sich die Nachrichten heute anguckt
mit diesem Dorf bei hakif wo über 50
Menschen getötet wurden so viele
Patriots kann man im Zweifelsfalle in
der Ukraine gar nicht aufstellen um die
Menschen wirklich zu schützen oder nein
das geht natürlich nicht sie können mit
Patriot Raketen können Sie strategisch
wichtige
Stellen schützen sie können eine Stadt
schützen sie können nicht ein ganzes
Land schützen und
wenn immer wieder Angst hat ja von
unserer Seite sozusagen von der
unterstützerseite würde eskaliert wir
sehen gerade dass Wladimir Putin nicht
bereit ist ähm irgendwie einzulenken er
zielt weiter auf Zivilisten heute 50
Tote ähm über kein militärisches Ziel
das ist ein Kriegsverbrechen was er
begangen hat und äh wir müssen die
Ukrainer äh weiter unterstützen damit
nicht weitere Ukrainer Opfer dieses äh
dieser Verbrecher Angriffe durch
Wladimir Putin sind Herr huskin danke ih
für das Gespräch sehr gerne Frau
zomker das Interview haben wir
aufgezeichnet und jetzt geht's bei dir
erstmal weiter Heinz mit anderen
Meldungen Bundespräsident Steinmeier
reist überraschend zu einem Treffen mit
US-Präsident Biden nach Washington er
werde am Freitag im Weißen Haus erwartet
teilte die usregierungszentrale am Abend
mit bei dem Treffen gehe es auch um die
enge Abstimmung als NATO Bündnispartner
in einer Reihe wichtiger Fragen
einschließlich der Verteidigung
demokratischer Werte und der gemeinsamen
Verpflichtung zur Unterstützung der
Ukraine aus dem Bundespräsidialamt hiese
Steinmeier Reise auf Einladung bidens
nach
Washington in Syrien sind bei einem
drohenangriff auf eine Militärakademie
in Homs nach Angaben der Regierung
mindestens 80 Menschen getötet und 240
verletzt worden die syrische Armee
erklärte bewaffnete Terrororganisationen
hätten die Abschlussfeier von Offizier
Studenten angegriffen wer den Angriff
verübt hat ist bisher nicht
bekannt bei einer internationalen
Konferenz zur Wiederauffüllung des
sogenannten grünen Klimafonds sind
Hilfen für ärmere Länder in Höhe von
umgerechnet knapp 8,9 Milliarden Euro
eingeworben worden darunter 2 Milliarden
Euro aus Deutschland laut
Bundesregierung sei das Geld von bisher
25 Geberländern zugesagt worden um
Projekte für die Zeit von 2024 bis 2 zu
finanzieren der grüne klimafond soll
Schwellen und Entwicklungsländern bei
der Anpassung an den Klimawandel und
beim Aufbau einer klimafreundlicheren
Wirtschaft
helfen die Versetzung des früheren AFD
Bundestags Abgeordneten Jens Meer in den
vorgezogenen Ruhestand als Richter ist
zulässig der Bundesgerichtshof
bestätigte heute eine Entscheidung des
Freistaates Sachsen und des zuständigen
dienstgerichts Meer war dagegen in
Revision gegangen hatte damit aber beim
BGH keinen Erfolg ihm wurde vorgeworfen
etwa durch wiederholte rassistische und
nationalistische Äußerungen seine
Glaubwürdigkeit als Organ der
Rechtspflege verloren zu
haben noch drei Tage bis zur
Landtagswahl in Hessen und in Bayern zu
den interessanten Beobachtungen in
diesen beiden Wahlkämpfen gehört ja wie
die Union damit umgeht dass ein
wachsender Teil der Wähler bereit ist
sein Kreuzchen rechts von ihr zu setzen
Markus Söder setzt eher auf Umarmung und
einen antigrüne Wahlkampf Boris rin in
Hessen regiert gemeinsam mit diesen
grünen und das sichtlich nicht ungern
unterschiedlicher könnten die
politischen Strategien in den
benachbarten Bundesländern also kaum
sein die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen hat nun
kurz vorm Wahltermin für beide Länder
ein letztes aktuelles Politbarometer
extra erstellt wir beginnen mit Bayern
wenn heute schon Landtagswahl wäre dann
sehee das so aus die CSU käme auf
37% die Grünen auf 16 die Freien Wähler
auf 15 AFD 14% dahinter die SPD mit 9%
die FDP würde aus dem Landtag fliegen
mit Maun
3%. das ist aber wie immer nur eine
Momentaufnahme Eindrücke vom entsport in
Bayern hat Alexander Pool
zusammengestellt dieses Bild erzählt
nicht die ganze Geschichte ja Markus
Söder holt Friedrich merärz des öfteren
in den bayerischen Wahlkampf ein
Stimmenfänger aber war er für die CSU
bislang nicht hier in Nürnberg greift
Söder zu einem Bekannten Wahlkampftrick
ampelbäching diese Ampel ist die
schlechteste Regierung die Deutschland
wahrscheinlich je gehabt hat meine d er
ist Söders ungeliebter Koalitionspartner
die Affäre um ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt hat Hubert eiwanger nicht
gescha
der an seiner parte nicht vorbemt eine
genug fürwanger mit seinen auritten
fischt er auch am rechten Rand mit
seinen Inhalten oft im bürgerlichen CSU
milie wir wollen unsere
jungidutahren dürfen Häuser bauen dürfen
Familien gründen können und reden dürfen
wie in der Schnabel
gewachsen Windkraft voraningen
solarenergieau Themen die heute in
München angesprochen werden doch hier
gerade hier bei den Grünen spielt die
politische Stimmung eine große Rolle und
so ist Hubert eiwanger gefühlt anwesend
wenn die Grünen lautstark einen
politischen Richtungswechsel fordern
indem wir eine nächste bayerische
Staatsregierung bekommen die eben nicht
Öl ins Feuer gießt die nicht das Lied
der Rechtspopulisten mitsingt denn das
macht deren Chor nur lauter und stärker
begleitet von Protesten fand in
Ingolstadt eine der letzten AFD
Kundgebungen vor der Wahlstatt
die momentane Debatte in der Asylpolitik
nutzt AFD Spitzenkandidatin Katrin Ebner
Steiner für ihren
wahlkampfschlager wir werden abschieben
abschieben abschieben das verspreche ich
euch eigentlich wollte auch eher in
Ingolstadt sprechen AFD Chef Tino
kopaller kurz nach seiner Ankunft aber
wird er wegen gesundheitlicher
Beschwerden in einen Krankenhaus
gebracht die AFD spricht wenige Minuten
später von einem tätlichen Angriff
angeblich eine Stichverletzung dem
widerspricht die Staatsanwaltschaft
heute Nachmittag Erkenntnisse über einen
Angriff legen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht vor es sei aber ein
Ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet worden
am frühen Abend dann teilt die AFD mit
Tino kupalla habe Ingolstadt
mittlerweile verlassen weit ab von
alldem die Sendlingerstraße in München
ein Foto mit dem SPD Spitzenkandidaten
Szenen die vergessen machen dass Florian
von Brunn in Bayern wenig bekannt istin
Wahlkampf freundlich engagiert die SPD
setzt hier in München auf das Thema
bezahlbares Wohnen bayernweit wirbt sie
mit kostenlosen
Kindertagestätten das FDP Kandidat
Martin Hagen zu Wasserstadt Wein greift
mag an den umfragewherten für seine
Partei liegen Hagen betont die
koalitionsfähigkeit mit der CSU und
bietet dafür jedem etwas an von der
knfusion bis zum Erhalt des
Verbrennungsmotors und in Hessen da
tritt ja mit Nancy fer immerhin eine
bundesinnenministerin als
Herausforderung des Herausfordererin des
amtierenden Ministerpräsidenten an doch
das von ihr ausgegebene Ziel die SPD zur
stärksten Kraft zu machen scheint in
weiter Ferne das Politbarometer extra
für Hessen sieht nämlich wie folgt aus
wenn heute schon Landtagswahl wäre käme
die CDU auf
32%. danach gleich auf grüne und sp
mit jeweils 17% die AFD käme auf 16 die
FDP würde mit 5% gerade so in den
Landtag kommen für die Linke reichte es
definitiv nicht und die Freien Wähler
die auch in Hessen antreten schafften
die Hürde auch nicht bis Sonntag kann
sich dann natürlich auch noch einiges
verschieben wie gesagt
Momentaufnahmen Momente auf den letzten
Metern des hässischen Wahlkampfs hat
auch Peter Wagner
eingefangen Heimspiel in Fulda
katholisches Herzland der CDU Hessen
Boris rin in der Rolle zwischen sunnyby
und Landesvater ist scheint als kenne er
hier Gott und die Welt bis zum Schluss
bleibt er seinem Wahlkampf Mantra treu
warnt vor der Ampel die es nach den
Umfragen gar nicht mehr geben
kann das Ziel unserer Mitbewerber der
SPD und der Grünen ist klar die wollen
eine ampelregierung eben auch für Hessen
ich sage Ihnen die Ampelkoalition ist
die schlechtest mögliche Regierungsform
für ein Land die Grünen haben heute in
Frankfurt alles an Prominenz aufgeboten
was die Partei hergibt wieder Gutmachung
für den Berliner Gegenwind der Tarik
alvasir im hessenwahlkampf ins Gesicht
bläst undter Spitzenkandidat schreibt
Harbeck berbock und Co ins Stammbuch
dass notwendige Veränderungen besser
kommuniziert werden müssen wenn wir die
Menschen auf diesem Weg verlieren haben
wir auch in der Sache nichts gewonnen
das ist die große auf ab und das ist
unsere auch meine Verantwortung in den
nächsten
Jahren frauenper geballt und farblich
abgestimmt der Termin mit den SPD
Ministerpräsidentin ist der bisherige
Höhepunkt von nency fäers hprrig im
Wahlkampf die Doppelbelastung als
Innenministerin und Spitzenkandidatin
mit Rückfahrkarte war heftig es gab
Pannen und Fehler zuletzt zog fäer in
SPD Schmäh Video gegen die CDU zurück
das mit Fälschungen eine Nähe zu AFD
unterstellte jetzt HFT die
Spitzenkandidatin auf unentschiedene und
auf andere Themen ich finde da wird sich
hier ein bisschen einfach gemacht das
nicht die erste Wahl die ich erlebe in
Hessen wo Bundespolitik im Vordergrund
steht das wäre schön wenn die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger am 10 nach
häsischen Themen entscheiden Kernthema
bei der AFD die Migration man verstehe
durchaus die Not der Menschen aber wir
sehen halt auch dass zu einem
erschreckend großen Teil eine
Einwanderung in unsere Sozialsysteme
stattfindet und meine Damen und Herren
dieser Satz muss sein wir sind nicht das
Sozialamt der Welt jedwedde
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD haben die
anderen Parteien klar
ausgeschlossen die Liberalen müssen um
den Einzug in den neuen Landtag bangen
die Linken können sich wohl keine
Hoffnungen mehr
machen weiter mit den Grünen oder
erstmals eine Kroko unter Führung der
Union das scheint in Hessen Mö
hat nach der Wahl die
Wahl und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit
Wirtschaft nach dem Auslaufen der
staatlichen Förderung für gewerbliche
Elektroautos ist die Zahl der neu
zugelassenen Batteriefahrzeuge im
September deutlich zurückgegangen rund
31700 kamen im vergangenen Monat neu auf
die Straße wie das kraftfaht Bundesamt
mitteilte das waren demnach fast 29%
weniger als im September des Vorjahres
insgesamt auf allen Antriebsarten
gerechnet wurden im September fast
genauso viele Pkw zugelassen neu wie vor
Jahresfrist und mit Frank betmann wollen
wir jetzt auf ein einzelnes Autowerk
schauen in salouis denn da gab's heute
wichtige Neuigkeiten ja leider keine
guten auf einer Betriebsversammlung
sollte den rund 4000 Beschäftigten heute
ein neuer Investor vorgestellt werden
ford hatte vor Monaten entschieden die
Produktion des Ford Focus von saloui
nach Spanien zu verlegen die Zukunft des
Werkes seitdem ungewiss Hoffnung war
also da die Nachricht per Videobotschaft
heute daher besonders
bitter leider hat der Investor uns nun
mitgeteilt dass er das Projekt nicht
weiter verfolgen möchte wie bereits
mitgeteilt werden wir am Standort saloui
1000 Ford Jobs bewahren bzw neu schaffen
1000 statt wie gehofft 3000 Jobs so
viele sollten nämlich nahtlos überführt
werden in ein Joint Venture auch die
Landesregierung war bereit kräftig
mitzuhelfen heute zunächst dann die
kalte Dusche inzwischen hört man das
möglicherweise doch weiter verhandelt
wird und was würde die Schließung für
das sarland bedeuten ja nicht wenige
fürchten sollte es wirklich so kommen
wäre es für das Saarland die größte
Katastrophe seit dem Ende des Bergbaus
ohne Ford oder einige Vergleiche oder
gleichwertige Ansiedlung werde das Land
weiter abgehängt heißt es dass Sa tut
sich mit dem Strukturwandel besonders
schwer die Einnahmen bescheiden die
Schulden vergleichsweise hoch da fehlen
einfach die Spielräume umzusteuern
vielen Dank Frank betmann nach
Frankfurt ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball
Europa League Freiburg verlor am Abend
im zweiten Gruppenspiel gegen westtham
United
1:2 Vogel des Jahres
2024 ist der kibitz die stark bedrohte
Vogelart erhielt bei einer öffent
Abstimmung unter 120.000 Menschen die
meisten Stimmen in Deutschland steht der
wiesenvogel mit der markanten Federhaube
auf der Roten Liste der gefährdeten
Brutvögel durch den Klimawandel und die
intensive Landwirtschaft verliert er
zunehmend an Lebensraum bundesweit leben
laut Schätzungen noch etwa 55 000
Brutpaare den literaturn Nobelpreis
bekommt dieses Jahr einer den vielleicht
noch nicht jeder kennt den aber viele
Literatur interessierte als Kandidat auf
dem Zettel hatten Jon fosse ist einer
der großen norwegischen gegenwarts
Schriftsteller und galt schon seit
vielen Jahren als möglicher Favorit den
berühmten Anruf der Akademie hat er
heute dort entgegengenommen wo er sich
am liebsten aufhält in der
Abgeschiedenheit eines Fjords er sei ein
wenig verängstigt sagte er danach großer
Trubel ist ihm eher unheimlich chr
lepple stellt uns wer und Autor
vor ein riesiger Lachs auf der Bühne
Symbol und Spielort für moderne
beziehungstram mit dabei toxische Männer
leidende Frauen schlaflos von jn fosse
vor z Jahren an der Berliner
stadsoper der Norweger ist einer der
meistgespielten Theaterautoren der Welt
und jetzt auch Nobelpreisträger
Interviews mag er
nicht na ja es ist nicht wirklich sehr
überwältigend
seit 2013 bin ich Teil der
nominierungsdebatte also habe ich mich
in einer bestimmten Weise schon darauf
vorbereiten können dann sind 9 Jahre
vergangen und es wurde viel darüber
geredet ach wieder kein Preis also
dachte ich dass es auch dieses Jahr
nicht passieren
wird John fosse stammt aus Bergen
Norwegen die Heimat von weltbekannten
Künstlern wie hen
oderedri hier wurde immer hartarbeitet
wenig gesprochen fosses Lebensmotto höre
den Menschen genau zu beobachte sie an
der Bushaltestelle oder in der Bar und
dann gibt dem unsagbaren eine Stimme das
eine gute Entscheidung weil er
einzigartig ist mit der Art wie er
schreibt also ich kenne niemanden der so
schreibt und das zeichnet ihn ja auch
aus das ist was Eigenes so eine eigene
Welt für mich ist er der der Becket
seiner Zeit und Becket war sehr sag mal
auch in seiner Zeit sehr innovativ
der 64jährige gilt als Meister der
leisen Töne über Abgründe in Familien
schreibt der Mutter tochterkonflikte
oder scheidungsdramen bei fosse reichen
wenige Worte um große Wirkung zu
erzielen stets gewürzt mit einem Schuss
Ironie gut 30 Romane und Theaterstücke
hat er geschrieben Interviews dagegen
gibt er
selten ich würde lieber im Hintergrund
bleiben das hat viel mit dem Schreiben
zu tun den kann man mit der Gesellschaft
und den anderen Menschen kommunizieren
ohne es wirklich tun zu
müssen jetzt steht der Norweger
plötzlich im Rampenlicht wegen seiner
innovativen Werke wie die jure schreibt
schlagzeih nicht ein
Ding nein ich habe keine
[Musik]
Geheimnisse der Rest aber ist ein großes
Geheimnis die finden sich genau in
seinen Geschichten nun ausgezeichnet mit
dem Nobelpreis für
Literatur das war's im heute journal bei
mabrit ilner geht's gleich weiter die
mit ihren Gästen über die Asylpolitik
debattiert und um 0:30 Uhr gibt's dann
unser heute journal Update mit nasan göt
mir bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
wiedersehen
guten Abend mögen sie Duelle am Sonntag
zeichnet sich am Himmel über uns eins ab
nämlich zwischen dem Tief über
Nordosteuropa und dem Hoch über
Frankreich damit verschärfen sich die
wettergegensätze bei uns am Sonntag und
am Montag das bedeutet Regen es bedeutet
aber auch tiefere Temperaturen im
Nordosten und sommerliche Wärme im Süden
Deutschlands jetzt schauen wir aber
erstmal auf die aktuelle Wetterlage und
die wird geprägt durch dieses hoch über
dem westlichen Mittelmeer das schleut
regentiefs heute Olli morgen Patrick im
Norden an sich vorbei das einzige tief
das sich wenig bewegt das ist das Tief
quiron hier über dem Atlantik zusammen
mit dem hochtora schaufelt es die
Sommerwärme zu uns heute Nacht fällt in
Norddeutschland Regen sonst ist es
stärker bewölkt und im Süden bildet sich
auch mal Nebel da kann es kalt werden da
sinken die Temperaturen zum Teil bis 2°
das bedeutet örtlichicht od da
Bodenfrost deutlich milder bleibt die
Nacht im Norden bei 14 bis 10° die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 16 und 22° und auch morgen über
Tag ziehen Regenwolken über
Norddeutschland bei einem lebhaften Wind
aus südwestlichen Richtungen sonst ist
es mal mehr mal weniger stark bewökt und
im Süden gibt's nach Nebel auch
Sonnenschein am Samstag fällt in
Norddeutschland viel Regen am Sonntag
erreicht der die Mitte dahinter wird es
deutlich kälter mit nur noch 13° im
Südwesten steigen die Werte dagegen bis
26°
guten Abend